You can tell tensions are running very high
within Donald Trump's inner circle because
of the start of this impeachment inquiry against
him and Donald Trump's lawyer, Rudy Giuliani
went on TV yesterday and absolutely lost it,
starting to call the other guests a moron.
And I get it. Everything is coming crashing
down around the Trump administration. They
are panicked. They're now planning to put
out what is effectively the bar letter 2.0,
I'll talk to you about that in the next segment.
Uh, with regard to the transcript of Trump's
phone call with the Ukrainian president in
July. So I understand why this is happening.
Check this out. Look at the abuse that Rudy
Giuliani, Trump's lawyer hurls at his fellow
guests on Fox news as Laura Ingram program.
The person Rudy Giuliani is attacking here
is Chris Hahn, who's a former aid to democratic
Senator Chuck Schumer. Clearly, Rudy is not
pleased with him. Take a look at this
irresponsible ways. Yeah. Well you are. You
actually usually say incredibly stupid things.
Public figure. Yeah. And uh, by the way, do
you have any idea that the state department
ain't go the library archival library shut.
Shut up. You don't know what you're talking
about, Chris. You don't know what you're talking
about. Idiot. I do this state. No, you don't.
You just fire. I wish you would stop. You
lied in front and stop. Mr [inaudible] wish
she would stop. Why don't you tell him to
keep his mouth shut so we can tell the truth.
Just keep your mind in mouth corresponding.
Okay. He said
now for a while, Rudy Giuliani was known for
drinking before going on evening television
shows that he would appear on and it was a
big problem for a while. People are in the,
around Trump are trying to keep Rudy Giuliani
on daytime shows because he wouldn't be drinking
before those, at least not, not often. I don't
know if that was a factor here, but yelling
shut up more on the day your client formally
becomes the target of an impeachment inquiry
does not exactly scream confident cooperation
for the benefit of your client. Does it? I
don't know that shut up moron totally clears
the president as Donald Trump often likes
to say. So first of all, I get it. This is
not good for anyone and everybody around Donald
Trump is panicking. Tensions are running extremely
high. The other thing is that Rudy Giuliani
could actually end up being a far more sinister
player in all of this than we've known up
till now.
And I think that in addition to an impeachment
inquiry into Donald Trump, Rudy Giuliani should
be investigated because Rudy, Rudy Giuliani
is the president's personal attorney and what
he's doing is traveling all around the world
lobbying on behalf of all sorts of different
interests, some of them foreign interests.
Rudy Giuliani was involved in his lobbying
Ukraine to smear Joe Biden that we know at
this point. Rudy's admitted it and uh, Trump
has admitted it. Uh, Rudy. Rudy Giuliani was
recently with Romanian leaders criticizing
anti-corruption efforts going on there. And
there are immediately questions about who
is Rudy Giuliani speaking for when he does
this stuff? Does he speak for the president?
Does he speak for the state department? Is
he communicating anything that is an official
or a pseudo official position for the U S
government? The government has clarified,
Rudy does not speak for them, but that actually
raises even more questions about who's paying
Rudy Giuliani for what he's doing.
Is he properly registered under Farrah for
the work that he is doing? Sometimes in the
interest of foreign governments, it's truly
unheard of. But that is the name of the game
here. All of this stuff is not okay. The Ukraine
stuff, the money laundering allegation, I
mean there's this long list of stuff, but
is anybody going to be held accountable for
it? Because that has been the Trump experiment.
Yeah, this stuff is not okay, but are they
going to do anything to us? And so far the
system has not actually dealt with what the
president's administration has been willing
to do and unless that changes, they are getting
away with all of it. Let me know what you
think about all of this, the wisdom of the
impeachment inquiry, how Democrats carry it
forward. I want to hear from you. I'm on Twitter
at D Pacman. The show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show, and so yesterday I said I was
going to be live streaming on Twitch. I ended
up live streaming on YouTube yesterday. Tonight
I am live streaming on Twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pakman. We'll be talking about [inaudible].
Listen, I hope
to see you there.